I want to build on what we did on the
last video a little bit so let's say we
have two random variables so I have
random variable X and let me draw its
probability distribution and actually it
doesn't have to be normal but I'll just
draw it as a normal distribution so this
is the distribution of random variable X
this is the mean the population mean of
random variable X and then it has some
type of standard deviation or actually
let me just focus on the variance so it
has some variance right here for random
variable X now let's say let me just
write this is X the distribution for X
and let's say we have another random
variable random variable Y let's do the
same thing for it let's draw it's its
distribution its distribution and let me
draw the parameters for that
distribution so it has some true mean
some population mean for the random
variable Y and it has some variance
right over here so it has very some
variance to this distribution and I've
drawn it it roughly normal once again we
don't have to assume that it's normal
because we're going to assume when we go
to the next level that when we take the
samples we're taking enough samples that
the central limit theorem will actually
apply but with that said let's think
about the sampling distributions of each
of these random variables so let's think
about the sampling distribution the
sampling distribution of the sample mean
of X the sample mean of X when the
sample size and let's say the sample the
sample size over here is going to be
equal to n and actually over here I'm
going to ah stay in green right now so
what is that going to look like well
it's going to be some distribution some
distribution and now we're assuming that
n is is a fairly large number so this is
going to be a normal distribution or can
be approximated with a normal
distribution notice I drew it having a
let me shift it over a little bit I'm
going to draw it a little bit narrow
because we learn from the central limit
theorem that the standard deviation
this thing that the standard deviation
so let me draw the mean so the
population mean of the sampling
distribution is going to be we're going
to denote it with this X bar that tells
us the distribution of the means when
the sample size is N and we know that
this is going to be the same thing as
the population mean for that random
variable and we know from the central
limit theorem we know from the central
limit theorem that the variance the
variance of the sampling distribution or
often called the standard error of the
mean is going to be equal to the
population is going to be equal to the
population variance the population
variance divided by this n right over
here divided by n divided by that n over
there and if you wanted the standard
deviation of this you just take the
square root of both sides now let's do
the same thing for random variable Y so
let's take the sampling distribution
sampling distribution of the sample mean
but here we're talking about Y random
variable Y and let's just say it has a
different sample size it doesn't have to
be a different one but it just shows you
that it doesn't have to be the same so
it has a sample sample size let's say it
has a sample size of M so let me draw
its distribution right over here once
again it'll be a narrower distribution
than the population distribution and it
will be approximately normal assuming
that we have a large enough sample size
and it's mean the set the mean of the
sampling distribution of the sample mean
is going to be the same thing as the
population mean we've seen that multiple
times same thing as the population mean
and it's variance its variance so the
variance over here so the variance for
the sample means or the standard error
of the mean actually this isn't the
standard error this is the I guess you
could well standard error would be the
square root of this so if I call this
the standard error mean that's wrong the
standard error of the mean is the square
root of this
standard deviation this is the variance
of the mean the variance of the mean
don't want to confuse you so the
variance of the mean here is going to be
the exact same thing it's going to be
the variance of the population it's
going to be the variance of the
population divided by our sample size
divided by our sample size and
everything we've done so far is complete
review it's a little different because
I'm actually doing it with two different
random variables and I'm doing it with
two different random variables for a
reason because now I'm going to define a
new random variable I'm now going to
define a new random variable that is
well we could just call it Z we'll just
call it Z but Z is equal to the
difference of our sample means Z is
equal to and now let me state with the
colors it's equal to the X sample mean
minus the Y sample mean minus the Y
sample mean so what does that really
mean well to get a sample mean you're
taking or at least for this distribution
you're taking n samples you're taking n
samples from this population over here
maybe n is 10 you're taking 10 samples
and finding it's mean that sample mean
is a random variable you could view that
sample mean let's say you take 10
samples from here and you get 9.2 when
you find their mean that 9.2 can be
viewed as a sample from this
distribution right over here same thing
if this right here is M you're taking or
if M right here is 12 you're taking 12
samples taking its mean and that sample
mean maybe it's 15.2 could be viewed as
a sample from this distribution as a
from the sampling distribution so what Z
is Z is a Z is a random variable where
you're taking n samples from this
distribution up here this population
distribution taking its mean that you're
taking M samples from this population
distribution up here taking its mean and
then finding the difference between that
mean and that means so it's another
random variable but what is the
distribution of Z what is going to be
the distribution of
so let's draw it let's draw it like this
well there's a couple of things we
immediately know about Z and we kind of
came up with this in the last video so
the mean the mean of Z instead of
writing Z I'm just going to write the
mean of X let me do that same shade of
green the mean of X bar which is the
mean of X minus or a sample from the
sampling distribution of X or the sample
mean of X minus the sample mean of Y so
the mean of this is going to be equal to
and we saw this in the last video in
fact I think I still have the work up
here yeah I still have the work right up
here the mean of the difference is going
to be the difference of the means the
mean of the difference is the same thing
as the difference of the means so the
mean of this new distribution right over
here is going to be the same thing as
it's going to be the mean of it's going
to be the mean of our sample mean minus
the mean of our sample mean of Y sample
mean of Y and this might seem a little
abstract in this video in the next video
we're actually going to do this with
concrete numbers and hopefully it'll
make a little bit more sense and the
whole just so you know where we're going
with this the whole point of this is so
that we can eventually do some
inferential statistics about differences
of means how likely is a difference of
means of two samples random chance or
not random chance or what is a
confidence interval of difference of
means that's what this is all building
up to so anyway we know the mean of this
distribution right over here and what's
the variance of this distribution and we
came up with that result in the last
video if we take if we're taking
essentially the difference of two random
variables the variance is going to be
the sum of those two random variables
and a whole point of that video is to
show you that hey you know it's not the
difference of the variances it's the sum
of the variances so the variance the
variance of this of this new
distribution and I haven't drawn the
distribution yet the variance of this
new distribution I'll just write X bar
minus y bar is going to be equal to the
sum of the variances of each of these
distribute
the variance of X bar plus the variance
of Y bar now what is actually let me
just draw this here just so we can
visualize another distribution although
I'm going to draw is a another normal
distribution so this is its mean so the
mean over here so this let me scroll
down a little bit so the mean over here
mean of X bar minus y bar is going to be
equal to the difference of these means
over here I don't have to rewrite it and
then it let me draw and then let me draw
its let me draw the curve and notice I'm
drawing a fatter curve I'm drawing a
fatter curve than either one and why am
I doing that because the variance here
is the sum of the variances here so
we're going to have a fatter curve it's
going to have a bigger variance or a
bigger standard deviation than either of
these so then we have some variance here
variance of X bar minus y bar now what
are these in terms of the original
population distribution well we came up
with that result those results right
over here we know what the standard
deviation we know that this thing we
know that this thing is the same thing
as the variance of the population
distribution divided by n we've done
this multiple multiple times so this is
going to be equal to what's this going
to be equal to this is this part right
here is the same thing as the variance
of our population distribution the
variance of our population distribution
and the X just means this is for random
variable X but there's no bar on top
this is the actual population
distribution not the sampling
distribution of the sample mean so that
divided by N and then if we want the
variance of the sampling distribution
for Y let me do that in a different
color I'll use blue because that was
what we were using for the Y random
variable that's going to be equal to
this thing over here and we've done this
multiple times same exact logic is this
the population distribution for Y
divided by M divided divided by M and so
once again I'll just write this out
front
this is the variance of the differences
of the sample means the differences of
the sample means and now if you wanted
the standard deviation of the
differences of the sample means you just
have to take the square root of both
sides of this if you take the square
root of this you get the standard
deviation of the difference of the
sample means is equal to the square root
the square root of the population
distribution of X the or the variance of
the population distribution of X divided
by n plus the variance of the population
distribution of Y divided by M and then
the whole reason why I've even done this
and this is just neat because it kind of
looks a little bit like a distance
formula and I'll kind of throw that out
there as we get more sophisticated with
our statistics and try to visualize what
all of this kind of stuff means in more
advanced topics but the whole point of
this is now we can we can make
inferences about a difference of means
if we have two samples and we want to
say and we take the means of both of
those samples and we find some
difference we can make some conclusions
about how likely that difference was
just by chance and we're going to do
that in the next video